today's one minute monday
is ignore the nitpickers in your life
you are going to have the people
who nitpick every little thing that you
do and say
and just try to bring you down i call
these people the little man
and you need to ignore them you need to
realize this is your life you're in
charge
and you need to live up to your own
expectations not the expectations of
other people
i posted a post on linkedin where i was
advising people if you want to connect
with people then you have to be
authentic and vulnerable and the guy
rises back to say vulnerable i don't
like that word i don't think it fits
i think what you meant to say is open
and human
and natural are you kidding me
it's the same thing you're gonna have
people
who are out there trying to change the
world who are trying to do good
who are trying to make the world a
better place
than when they came into it they want to
leave the world
and have left it as a better place than
when they came into it and then you're
going to have the other people
who contribute nothing who just try to
bring other people down
and they don't like the words that you
use and they don't like the way that you
say something
and instead of doing something
meaningful with their life they're
trying to bring you down
pay these people no mind the bigger your
dream
the bigger the thing you're trying to
chase the more you're trying to change
the world
the more people are going to nitpick at
you are going to attack you are going to
tell you your ideas are wrong and stupid
don't listen to the little man trust
your heart
believe those who watching like the
video let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much i'll see you soon